Okay, I thought I got invited.
It's going very well, Andrew, actually.
Well, yeah, not too bad.
Actually, I went to the ocean today.
I just got back at about four o'clock,
so we left early and I spent the day on
the beach.
So it's been a long time since I went,
so I actually got really badly burnt,
but it was a good day.
Good day.
How about you?
How have things been?
Good.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Yeah,
normally it's just, you send in an
application, you mail it in, and then you
wait like four or six weeks.
But it depends on, I suppose, the country,
I imagine it's different in different
places, so.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Are you going to tell me, are you going to
answer it to me in Russian, or are you
going to translate it into English?
That actually would be quite funny,
but no, no, no, that's good.
It's not a bad way to work on that way,
so that's cool.
How has work been before we get started?
Like just over the last 10 to 14 days,
have you been doing anything at work?
Project?
Do...
Yeah, well, no, it's, I'm sure you saw
something in English, like maybe music,
right?
Or probably heard some songs or music in
English, if I had to guess, in the last 10
days you were listening.
Maybe not, but...
Oh, okay.
So you've still been, so you've been still
consuming, just not talking so much,
let's say, to a human being, so,
and that's fine.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a good warm-up place, actually,
I mean, it's, depending on the topic and
the people that you get, I suppose it can
be hit and miss, as it's called,
right, so it could be good or not so good,
just depending, but no, that's good,
always.
And yeah, to translate your transition,
your brain into English thinking,
by warming up for an hour is solid.
Yeah, the, there's a guy in his mid-20s
that lives in the village here,
and he, you call it mentally slow,
so he knows what he's doing, big guy,
too, for a Filipino, it's actually most of
the, most of the people here are quite
small, as you know, anyway, so he's
mentally slow.
He was in a fight with his parents or
something, and so my car, my SUV is parked
actually quite a ways from the house,
it's probably 200 or 300 metres,
so, and I gotta walk across a bridge that
goes across a river, anyway, I'm not close
to, close to the vehicle, so I don't know
him very well, but apparently he got into
a, a big argument with his family,
and he started throwing rocks,
and he ended up throwing a rock at our
car, hit the window and shattered it,
so, as you can imagine, in the remote area
that we live, it's been, it's been a lot
of fun, let's say, trying to source a
windshield and all sorts of other things
to get it installed, so I just got it,
the day, yeah, last, yeah, Tuesday,
when we were gonna meet, I actually was
back in time for five o'clock,
which was surprising, it was the most
efficient business I've worked with in the
Philippines to date, so I arrived at one,
my appointment was at 12.15, and I got the
keys at 2.30, so, anyway, I got the window
fixed and tinted, and there's still some
stuff, the dents in the vehicle,
but it's been a, it's been a lot of fun,
yeah,
yeah, so what we had to do is we phoned
the, I phoned the police, so the police
came and did a police report, and then
what you do here is you take people,
what's called to the barangay,
so the barangay is like the local village
elders, it's so different than Canada,
probably very different than, you know,
Kyrgyzstan and Rakhine, but it's the local
village elders, and they first make a
decision, anyways, yeah, the parents are
paying us installments, they gave us
actually money yesterday, and then we have
two more middle of the month, and then at
the end of the month, so, covering most of
the costs, let's say, but what it doesn't
cover is the time, right, like it's,
you try to explain to people here about
that, like, you know, time is very
important to people around the world,
but not here, so, you know, when I went to
General Santos today, the window was
fixed, it took me the whole day,
right, and then I went to the mountains,
you know, two hours back, plus sitting
there for three or four hours,
and, you know, and then all the time it
took to try to locate a place to do it,
and, you know, so, and, you know,
I'm only halfway done, so, long answer I
gave you, but the short answer is yes,
they are paying for most of it,
but it's a real challenge, let's say.
Yeah, yeah, you know, the gas,
the time, the stress, the, you know,
I couldn't, I couldn't go anywhere for
nine or ten days, the glass is shattered
in the vehicle, so, you know, I have to
get it, bring it to the detail,
and get it thoroughly vacuumed out,
it's, you know, in Canada it would have
been done in an hour, right, yeah,
basically there's so many places you can
go, and they're very effective and
organized in that way, here not so,
but it wasn't bad, you know, the actual
experience once I found the place,
and booked the time, and, you know,
it's, but it's, because here having a car
is so important, because there's no public
transport, there's nothing, right,
everyone here drives a motorcycle,
or a scooter, or a tricycle, or a vehicle,
so, you know, and driving a motorcycle,
or a scooter is dangerous, right,
the roads are bad condition, yeah,
so you're much safer in a car,
uh, never mind the weather, right,
there you can get caught in a pretty nasty
rainstorm, they come up pretty quick,
right, when you're in the tropics,
uh, yeah, but, no, overall I'm happy it's,
uh, fixed, and, um, so, yeah, that was
the, that was the conundrum, the,
the stress, I suppose, that we had in the
last, uh, two weeks or so, other than
that, it's been pretty normal,
uh, lots of working every day,
and today was the first day I had a little
bit of rest, I didn't do anything this
morning or afternoon, so we drove,
like I said, to the beach, so it's really
nice, yeah, so now it's good, I was
thinking about before, you know,
when I did this yesterday, or early this
morning, I was thinking, I wonder what we,
I was really, I, I spent some time
thinking what we should do, because,
you know, we've done a few different,
um, less than plans and approaches over
the last couple weeks, uh, minus the
break, and, yeah, I think it's,
uh, I think it was time to, to,
to just do a little bit of a dry run,
warm up on some of the questions,
and I, I think we'll see how, uh,
how it goes.
I tried to keep the questions,
uh, more on the, the concept of technical,
rather than something technically
specific, so we'll, we'll move into that
probably in the coming weeks, you know,
like something focusing on, you know,
CSS or XML, or, but the, the questions
that are in the agenda are pretty,
uh, pretty technically generic.
I think that's a good starting point.
So, have you gone through most of it,
besides the tell me about yourself,
or, uh,
oh, okay, okay, no worries.
Mm-hmm,
good, yeah,
okay, yeah, okay, okay, good, good.
The other thing I would like you actually
to read this passage, and maybe even both,
uh, I've been doing this with all of the
software engineers, both front and back,
um, when you and I started this journey,
you know, interviewing, um, one of the
things that's equally important,
when you are going to be interviewing,
is not in your answers, focusing only on
the technology, you know, it's probably an
80 to 20 split, where you focus on the,
the, the technology at 80%, and then 20%
on the impact, the business impact,
that why are you technically doing this,
right?
Um, too many technical engineers focus on
the tech, and, and so, um, this is really
what recruiters and human resources are
looking for, technical mastery with
business articulation, and even more
importantly, and probably, you know what,
we'll just probably read this way,
this is probably a little bit better,
because it gives a pretty good example of
what, what I'm, what I mean.
So, it's, you know, what, what human
resources, people and culture and talent
acquisition teams truly, uh, evaluate
your, uh, answers on.
So, let's start with this, we haven't read
a passage in a long time, but this will
get you warmed up as well, and when you're
answering in Russian and translating it in
English, have this kind of in mind.
So, when you're, yeah, yeah,
yeah, whenever you're ready, whenever
you're ready, you can read it at your
discretion, ability,
yeah, yeah,
yeah, story.
Actually, this is, well, I'll keep going,
but I'll, I'll mention, this is actually
how people write their resumes,
this is actually not a, I wrote that
specific, yeah,
that's, yeah, yeah,
yes, yes,
well, uh, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly,
and, you know, the assumption is you
understand the technology, or you would
not be applying for it, right?
So, it's more, you know, the way the,
the, the, these types of senior roles are
moving is, you know, they're multi,
multi-skilled in that not only are you
working with a team to build things,
but, you know, you go to client meetings,
you respond to clients sometimes,
you know, sometimes you're internal,
and you, you never see a cloud customer,
and that's normal, but, you know,
more and more resources are doing,
you know, multiple things, including being
brought to client-facing meetings,
especially if you're really good at what
you do, but you can see a clear
distinction, right?
Our, this is the way I used to write mine
too, like, I would say, I led a,
you know, led multi-million dollar
projects for, you know, digital healthcare
that included a FHIR HL7 bi-directional
integration between two hospital systems,
right?
But it doesn't, it doesn't talk about
volume, it doesn't talk about why this is
important, what impact it creates,
right?
So, it's exactly as this kind of sentence
is written out, right?
It's totally, you know, this is very
specific because it has the business
impact, as you talked about.
So, it's, it's, and, you know,
it doesn't have to be, it's balanced,
is how I would describe it.
I've never been a fan of seeing CVs that
have all these percentages and values
written all over the place, because the
first thing I'm going to ask in an
interview is, how did you, how do you
justify these percentages?
How did you, how did you actually come to
these values?
Explain that to me, please.
Is it, is it reporting statistics?
Is it analytics?
Is it, because, you know, how long,
and you try to catch people about,
you know, the statistics or values that
they're putting in their resume or their
CV.
And so, you know, if, if I asked you a
question, oh, so when did you,
when did you architect this SSR pipeline?
Was it this year?
Yeah, yeah, it was this year.
It was probably about six months ago.
Well, how do you know that you saved
35,000 euros?
How did you possibly convert that,
you know, because you can only calculate
how much your, how much your operational
OPEX costs were year to year.
Like, right, you get the, you get invoices
last year, and then you're going to get
invoices this year.
How do you know it was 35,000 less,
right?
Things like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, so be mindful when, if you do,
if you do update your CV in this way,
it doesn't have to be so specific.
I, I, I've never been a fan of putting
dollar amounts, and I, I just,
I like the level of where it's like,
let's say it replaced manual data entry
with automation, right?
We, we, you know, built a workflow that
fully automated a manual workflow or
process that saved a significant amount of
time, right?
Not, you know, three weeks out of a year
or something like that.
It's used, you use those business terms
like significant amount of time.
It kind of has the same impact without the
percentages or the numbers, and I,
I found that that's the way I,
I would, that would be more than enough
information for me if I was reviewing a
resume or a CV, and I would want to talk
to the individual in an interview.
So,
yeah, yeah, exactly.
And it is, it's safer too, right?
So, yeah, quantifiable KPIs, as you've
mentioned, you know, you know,
what are either the stats or at least
using words like automate and removing
manual, manual, and then ultimately,
you know, what, what, what, what soft
skills do you have, you know, mentoring
junior staff and being the most highest
expert in certain areas, people learn from
me, right?
And then ultimately, you know,
you work with lots of different teams.
So, yeah, so, so we won't go through the,
we won't go through the terms,
but you can at your discretion.
You've, we've reviewed a lot of these
already in past lessons.
Okay.
And so, this is broken up 12 behavioral
interview questions, or, and, or
technical.
So, it's, you know, your soft skills,
your collaboration, your leadership and
problem solving.
So, that's more kind of the level.
You know, how we, we kind of talked about
this before in terms of the framework
situation, like set the quick background.
What, what, what was, what were you trying
to do?
And then what, what, what did you actually
do?
Like, so what are you trying to solve?
What did you actually do to solve it?
And then what was the business outcome?
We were able to have our consumers return
to buying things within an hour.
So, yeah, yeah,
sure.
Okay.
Well, yeah.
So, let's try this one since you've been
working on it in Russian and translating.
So, and I'll listen.
So, Andrew, thanks for taking the time.
Why don't, why don't we start off with,
if you could tell us a little bit about
yourself, you know, your background,
your experience as a front-end engineer in
your career, I'd love to hear.
Yeah, yeah, of course, of course.
Well, let's pause for a minute.
Are you, are you looking at a Russian
paragraph and then you're, you're,
you're, so you don't have it sort of in
English, you have it in Russian and then
you're, oh, let's see if you're,
why not, well, although, but why not,
why not just refer to the English one
rather than looking at the Russian?
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yeah.
As I said, this is a practice session.
You, you speak very well.
It's just, this is, this is not only an
important question, but it's a long
question.
And you, you do this a few times and
you'll get used to this given the,
yeah, given the improvements you've made.
Yeah.
Given the improvements.
Sure.
It's okay.
It was going good until that, it was going
good until that point, actually.
When you slowed down, when you slowed down
and started talking about your,
because it's descriptive language you're
using, it was very good.
So until you got to that exact point,
yeah, until you get to that exact point,
whether it's the translation issue or you
got caught up on a word, it's not a big
deal because that can be fixed.
Yeah.
Great.
Okay.
No, the, you know, so the story that
you've put together, the descriptive
introduction is actually good,
whether it's in Russian or English.
And the way that you were describing it is
actually also good.
Outside of a few areas where you had a
translation, let's say, issue with
endlessly or endless and a few other
sections, I think you can work on,
you can work with that.
No problem.
The way that you're answering it is
totally fine.
Well, let's keep going.
We'll talk about what to focus on for next
time.
Well, thanks for that, Andrew.
And, you know, lots of good examples.
So that's great.
Moving forward, what was the, you know,
why are you interested in making a career
move right now?
You know, you just mentioned you're almost
done the CRM milestones.
You're near the finish line.
So what's the driver for you wanting to
make a move right now into another
position?
Suspended?
Oh.
Okay.
In a way, you're right.
So how you want to position this is that
the major initiative that you're,
that is coming to the conclusion is,
which is going to be successful,
is wonderful.
And you believe now is the time,
rather than starting something new again,
to focus elsewhere.
You've always wanted to work
internationally.
And you believe at this point in your
career, it's the right move.
You know, you want to continue to enhance
your professional experience and skills,
you know, moving forward.
So, you know, you're proud of what you've
done to date, with both the ERP and CRM
major initiatives at the oil and gas firm.
And now is actually the perfect time for
you to, now that they're winding down,
to look for something new.
I can still stay with the current
organization.
And there might be something large that
comes up again.
But I think now is the perfect stepping
stone for something new.
So you answer it that way.
Right?
Well,
no, but it's good because now
transcription is on too, right?
So we can digest the wording, right?
So that's awesome.
No, thank you.
Thank you as well.
Thank you too.
But yeah, that's the story you'll say.
So, you know, yes, the team will be
disbanded.
It doesn't mean you lose your job.
It just means that you're going to focus
on something else, right?
And so if you're going to focus on
something else, now is the time to do it
elsewhere, is really the simple answer.
And it's the truth.
Right?
So it's good.
Really good.
Sure.
National.
Yeah.
Multinational or international.
Depends on how you want it.
Yeah.
Now is the logical time to do it.
So it's perfect.
Very good answer.
You can keep it simple.
So absolutely.
Okay.
Regarding communication, you know,
you had mentioned you've worked on two
major initiatives over the last few years
and worked with numerous teams.
And you've worked on two major
initiatives, if not more.
One thing that's important is
collaboration between teams.
So how would you ensure smooth
communication and alignment when working
with back-end developers, right?
That everyone knows what's going on.
What do you normally do?
How do you ensure that happens?
Sure.
Also, don't forget about also like if we
can put in transcription, don't also
forget about the tools that you use to
ensure smooth communication, right?
So JIRA or whatever you utilize to put
information into your user stories and
within the sprints.
So usually there's lots of information
that's included both from the front and
back end if it's a certain feature.
And you review it together, right?
If there's a need, you know, or a
requirement to confirm a few technical
things, you certainly would during the
review second for the upcoming sprint talk
about a particular feature or initiative
from an architectural perspective,
both from front and back end.
And, you know, are there any gaps or are
we all understanding what needs to be
done?
That kind of thing.
So you described the soft skills,
which is very good.
What you also need to then include is the
hard skills around the tools that you use
to review the actual technical feature.
Yeah.
But you described it well in English,
the soft side.
So that's fine.
You would have had maybe the same
challenge in Russian as you do in English,
right?
So it's focusing on the tools you use to
communicate and also the soft skills to
review verbally and technically and how
that might be.
So that's fine.
It's good.
Sure.
Very, very good answer.
You don't have to say anything more than
that.
Sometimes a shorter answer is important.
So that's how you ensure smooth
communication, right?
You know, in order to avoid technical
challenges later between back and front
end, you review exactly as you said.
So you don't need to say any more and you
said it flawlessly.
We're good.
Okay.
Let's move into a little bit of problem
solving.
We can try one more.
Do you remember a time, curious,
you know, does something stand out maybe a
little bit more around a critical bug
reached production?
And what did you do?
So it's a really large or critical bug,
you know, not we all have defects,
but is there one that stands out in your
experience that you'd like to kind of
highlight?
Medium level?
Yeah.
Okay.
So one potential way to answer this type
of question first is you have to assess
the situation first, right?
So you have to analyze how severe is the
defect?
So, you know, because it's production,
it's impacting your customers or your
users.
So before doing anything, you absolutely
have to determine what the impact of the
defect is.
You know, is it severe, medium or lower?
And is it something that you believe you
can resolve in a relatively fast way?
If it's a severe or critical production
issue, really the next step is to
determine, do we have to roll back after
we deployed?
Or is this something that we can address
in a reasonable amount of time?
And, you know, those factors are
determined by how severely impacted our
users or our customers are.
You know, if they're not able to do
something critical to the reason they're
paying us money to use our tech,
we have to look at rolling back.
Fortunately, and so this is where you now
answer the question you just did.
Fortunately, I've never had to roll back a
production environment yet.
Each time these types of scenarios have
come up, we've determined that they've
been, you know, from a critical
perspective, they've been medium or,
let's say, lower based priorities.
And we were able to resolve them within
production, rather than having to roll
back.
So perhaps the technical team is very good
at what they do.
Perhaps we've been a little bit fortunate
and lucky in some ways, because it
happens.
Rolling back a production environment is,
let's say, not common, but it happens.
And I've just been fortunate not to have
to roll back.
Yeah, yeah.
Sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, good.
So it's a good, it's a very good answer.
Because, yeah, exactly.
Like, so the, you can also,
you can also, you can be a little bit
fictitious to say, you know, the true
answer here that they're looking for is,
yes, a critical bug means typically,
we have to make a business decision.
Are we going to roll back or not?
So they want to see you being able to,
you know, put that kind of hat on when
you're answering this question,
right?
The decision to roll back or not is
somewhat technical.
But it's not the underlying decision that
makes you roll back or not.
It's the business impact.
Are your users unable to log in now?
Or are they not able to buy?
Or, you know, use critical workflow?
And if they're not, the decision's easy,
you roll back.
So yeah, the answer you gave was really,
really good.
So look at the transcript when we digest
it.
And, you know, we can incorporate it into
your response.
Yeah, we can do it.
We can do another.
Yeah, no, we can do it.
Yeah.
Let's do, we'll do one more, and then
we'll do a little bit of a debrief.
So,
you know, you mentioned you're part of a
few different development teams,
and you collaborate cross-functionally.
Do you have any actual experience
mentoring junior engineers or onboarding a
new developer to your team?
How do you, and how, if so, how do you
normally approach it?
You could say, you know, I'm very happy
that I got another slave.
It makes my stress much less.
What's another word for slave?
Yeah, yeah, hiring a new team member,
hiring a new employee or a new team
member.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
Well, you can answer it by, you can end it
by, like, just reconfirming the question.
So, no, that's how I mentor, you know,
new staff or onboard new engineers.
You know, multiple ways.
Yeah.
You just repeat the question, if that's an
approach that you like.
Reconfirm it.
No, that's good.
Okay.
No, not a bad first run, to be honest.
You're not pausing, you're not getting
stuck anymore, which is great.
We just have to define the answer.
We're at the stage now where we're
defining really good responses for you,
right, rather than getting frustrated by
not knowing the word or, you know,
you've had a little bit of a break as
well.
So, that's good.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a lot different now.
Okay.
Is it perfect?
No, of course not, but it never will be.
But what you have to do is you have to
gain the confidence to realize that
they're not assessing your minor mistakes
or a few minor pauses.
They want to hear the answer.
And if you have the capability of giving a
little bit of an answer, both quickly and
slowly, and in certain places,
it's fine, as long as you can provide a
relatively good answer.
So, you know, you had mentioned that you
talked about, you know, tell me a little
bit about yourself.
So, one thing that was missing,
so this is nothing to do with English,
this is to do with how you answer this
type of question, is the business impact
again.
So, whether you choose to do it on the ERP
side or on the CRM side, you had
mentioned, you know, all the milestones
were delivered and the product is almost
ready or finished.
So, what would be beneficial, even though
I don't want your answers to become
longer, I want them to be shorter,
I would suggest they become shorter,
is that you need to incorporate at least
one or two specific examples of what was
enhanced or what made this CRM better for
everybody.
You know, was it automating the email
exchanges between clients and customer
support?
Was it your business development account
managers or account executives being able
to communicate in a much more seamless and
strategic way?
Was it enhancing the database that can
capture, you know, a lot more detailed
information about an organization and
their contacts?
Was it improving the purchasing experience
of the consumers?
You know, those things.
You don't have to talk about the
technical, you talked about the major
features that you worked on that were very
well received.
Yeah, no problem.
It's good.
You just add it to, you know, so I
technically led a team that focuses on
this, that's, you know, focused on the CRM
environment, supporting our healthcare
clients.
You said this really well and then,
you know, we're getting really close to
having almost all of the original
milestones delivered and, you know,
a few of them were, you know, enhancing
the purchasing workflows for whatever the
examples you want to give.
Yeah, goes well.
I'm just reviewing the other, yeah,
and then lastly, quick, Andrew,
if you look at some of these other
questions, it's just, you know,
so it's broken, you know, this was
actually, I really like this one,
adaptation and growth, so tell me about a
time you had to learn a new framework,
library, or tool for a project,
something really fast, right?
How do you estimate, right, how do you
estimate your user stories?
And then, you know, where do you see
yourself growing professionally over the
next two or three years?
And then there, it transitions into a
little bit of the initially easy technical
questions about, you know, how do you
explain this to a non-technical person?
This is a very popular interview question,
like, how do you explain the difference to
a non-technical person, right?
And so on and so forth.
We can go through this next time or in the
coming sessions.
Good.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
A lot of good content.
Yeah.
Good.
That's good.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And it's nice that we have Craig to,
you know, digest the words and put it into
a script.
So, that'll be helpful to me.
Good, good, good.
Are you?
Not a problem.
Have a very nice, you know, weekend ahead.
It's nice that it's, the weekend is here
and, or soon for you as well.
And we'll talk on Tuesday.
Okay.
Thank you.
See you on Tuesday.
Bye-bye.